(Se que a veces parezco demasiado apasionado.
Sé que a muchos de ustedes no les gusta esto,
pero esta elección no se trata de mí, se
trata de vos.
Esta lección se trata de Si queremos seguir
por este rumbo que hace décadas nos conduce
al fracaso o si queremos hacer algo distinto
[...] Punto y aparte)
Javier Gerardo Milei se ha convertido en el
fenómeno político del momento.
Ojo, no solo en Argentina.
Su victoria en las PASO lo ha catapultado
a nivel internacional.
Ahora son muchos quienes quieren sacar tajada
de su victoria, de una u otra forma:
N1(López Obrador evocó los fantasmas de
Hitler y el nazismo al explicar el triunfo
de Milei.
LaNación)
N2(El bolsonarismo celebró la victoria de
Milei en las PASO: "Puede ser el cambio real
que la Argentina necesita".
Perfil)
Por primera vez un candidato libertario tiene
serias posibilidades de hacerse con la presidencia
de un país como la Argentina.
Si el fenómeno Milei era una incógnita y
una simple manifestación de hartazgo, tras
las PASO se ha convertido en una opción totalmente
real.
N3(El banco de Wall Street que anticipa un
triunfo de Milei en las elecciones presidenciales:
Según Wells Fargo, el candidato liberal tiene
65% probabilidad de ser electo presidente
este año.
Bloomberg)
N4(Javier Milei anticipó que lo contactaron
del FMI y en los próximos días se reunirán.
InfoBAE)
Ahora bien, ¿Cómo surgió semejante ola
libertaria en el país gaucho?
¿De dónde viene y qué posiciones tiene
exactamente Milei?
¿Cuál es su plan para la Argentina?
Pues queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo
vamos a responder todas estas preguntar.
Vamos a descubrir que hay tras el tsunami
Milei.
Arranquemos.
Pese a sus grandes idas y venidas en materia
económica, la política argentina ha tenido,
en cierto modo, un hilo conductor más o menos
constante.
En la primera parte del siglo XX, con la consolidación
democrática, surgió la Unión Cívica Radical,
el primer gran partido de masas que, de hecho,
ganó las tres primeras elecciones abiertas:
las de 1916, 1922 y 1928.
Luego las Fuerzas Armadas se metieron de lleno
en la vida con el golpe de 1930.
A partir de ese momento la democracia argentina
fue, digamos, intermitente, los golpes de
Estado se sucedieron y durante años la democracia
se limitó a determinados periodos de tiempo.
En uno de esos espacios surgió Juan Domingo
Perón, quien fundó el movimiento peronista…
Y sentó las bases de lo que sería a partir
de entonces las bases de la democracia argentina:
Por un lado, el anti-peronismo, habitualmente
vinculado a la Unión Cívica Radical y otros
aliados y, por otro, el peronismo, sostenido
por el Partido Justicialista.
Ya lo tenemos.
Este es el tándem que desde el regreso de
la democracia en 1983 ha dominado por completo
la política argentina.
En la última década, este dueto ha estado
representado, en sus distintos nombres, por
la coalición opositora Juntos por el Cambio,
y por la coalición oficialista peronista,
Unión por la Patria.
Y así fue hasta que una tercera fuerza vio
hueco y de repente se coló en la política
de un país con una economía devastada.
Por supuesto, estamos hablando de La Libertad
Avanza, el partido político de Javier Milei.
En las PASO de 2023, los libertarios no solo
lograron una victoria nacional sin precedentes,
sino que obtuvieron una enorme cantidad de
votos en el interior del país, en provincias
y municipios que eran auténticos bastiones
peronistas.
De hecho, tanto en la capital federal como
en la Provincia de Buenos Aires, Juntos por
el Cambio y Unión por la Patria lograron
retener su caudal de votos.
Es decir, que Javier Milei logró su triunfo
nacional gracias a sus victorias en lugares
donde ningún detractor del peronismo había
logrado semejante hazaña, por lo menos en
las últimas 5 décadas
Pero, ¿Cuál fue exactamente la ventana de
oportunidad que aprovechó Milei?
¿Cómo demonios logró generar semejante
vorágine electoral, un tipo que llegó a
la política en 2019?
Estas son las dos primeras preguntas qué
tenemos que responder antes de ver exactamente
qué es lo que quiere hacer Milei con la Argentina.
Así que…
Vamos con ello.
T1(LA SEMILLA: EL DESENCANTO MACRISTA)
El corralito y el colapso del 2001 dieron
paso a un país donde el tipo de cambio, el
último dato de inflación y los salarios
acaparan una atención social desmedida.
Quizás por eso, aunque te pueda resultar
extraño en el país de la crisis eterna,
la economía es la titulación número 1 en
la universidad argentina.
Cada año se gradúan en la Argentina casi
15.000 economistas.
La constante crisis ha hecho que en la Argentina
los temas económicos acaparen un enorme y
creciente protagonismo político y social.
La economía es la auténtica rockstar del
debate político.
En Argentina, en las cenas de Navidad, la
inflación es un tema popular.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Gracias a toda esta vorágine mediática,
un buen día encontró espacio en los medios
de comunicación, un economista que poco a
poco iría sobresaliendo del montón.
Estamos hablando, por supuesto, de Javier
Milei.
Esto es del 25 de agosto de 2015.
Fijaos.
(La alternativa digamos que la que he
estado trabajando es la de colocar un
bono si en dólares que vos los
suscribirse en pesos sí y eso va a
permitir eliminar el sobrante de dinero)
Poco a poco, y gracias a la campaña de 2015,
el nuevo icono libertario, comenzó a tener
cada vez más y más presencia en los medios
de comunicación.
Por aquella época, Milei tenía en sus intervenciones
un perfil más técnico.
Destacaban sobre todo sus críticas a las
intervenciones de precios que había llevado
a cabo el gobierno de Cristina Fernández
de Kirchner.
Sea como sea, el caso es que en esas elecciones
el peronismo perdió.
Maurició Macri se convirtió en el nuevo
presidente de Argentina el 10 de diciembre
de ese mismo año.
Las esperanzas de un gran cambio eran más
que palpable.
Las expectativas estaban por las nubes…
Seguramente demasiado altas.
“Porque yo hoy estoy acá porque creo en
ustedes y necesito que ustedes también crean.
Crean que sol n capaces de más, que pueden
hacer más y merecen vivir mejor.
[...] Un beso enorme, enorme para todos.
Los amo, amo a este país y los amo a cada
uno de ustedes."
El gobierno de Macri tuvo que lidiar con un
montón de problemas…
En 2016, el debate, el gran debate, era si
el nuevo gobierno debería aplicar una política
de Shock o apostar por un programa gradual
que fuese introduciendo los cambios poco a
poco.
Pues bien, al final ganó, esta segunda posibilidad.
El intento de buscar una cierta estabilidad
durante las reformas y un mayor nivel de consenso
y paz social hicieron que gobierno fuese tan
gradual que al final la mayoría de los cambios
eran apenas perceptibles.
De esta forma, muy pronto, el macrismo incumplió
todas las expectativas que estaban puestas
en esta nueva era.
Al final ni el gasto pública se estaba reduciendo
tanto, ni se terminaba con el déficit ni
se terminaba por aprobar una gran liberalización
de la economía.
Todo seguía más o menos igual.
N5(29 de julio de 2017: Déficit fiscal: se
cumple la meta, pero aún retrasa el crecimiento
. El Gobierno mantiene su estrategia de reducción
gradual del rojo presupuestario, al que financia
con deuda, pero también condiciona la recuperación
de la actividad en 2017.
InfoBae)
Fue entonces cuando Milei se posicionó como
un referente de aquellos que coincidían con
el primer camino: ir a rápido y a fondo.
Fue aquí cuando nació la versión más encendida
de este candidato.
La fórmula que lo llevaría a convertirse
en la tercera vía de la política argentina.
N6(29 de mayo de 2017: Milei advirtió que
los planes de ajuste graduales “terminan
en crisis”.
Cronista)
Desde mi punto de vista, este gobierno es
el socialismo amarillo.
No creo que sean corruptos, pero si son colectivistas
si les gusta el gasto público si digamos
o sea le gusta la intervención del estado.
Al final el gobierno de Macri fue un desastre.
Con la inflación por las nubes y una malísima
situación económica, tuvo que terminar pidiendo,
otra vez, un rescate al FMI.
Por supuesto, en las siguientes elecciones
volvió el peronismo, y lo hizo, además,
por la puerta grande: ni siquiera les hizo
falta llegar a segunda vuelta.
En esas elecciones de 2019, hubo alternativa
liberal, la de José Luis Espert.
Apenas logró el 1,47% de los votos, pero
supuso abrir una vía que ya no se cerraría.
En las siguientes legislativas, Espert y Milei
lideraron una alternativa conjunta que sumo
casi 1,3 millones de votos.
Los únicos que estamos proponiendo un cambio
de sistema, para que Argentina no sea la villa
miseria más grande del mundo, somos nosotros.
Este fue el gran debut político de Milei,
que terminó siendo diputado por la Capital
Federal con el 17% de los votos.
En total, a nivel nacional la plataforma liberal
logró 4 diputados.
Ese fue el comienzo.
A partir de ahí el protagonismo de Milei
creció como la espuma.
Con el peronismo otra vez en el gobierno,
su mensaje duro empezó a calar más y más.
Milei se convirtió de repente en una de las
principales figuras de la oposición.
Y claro, con un gobierno tan desastroso y
encima, con la pandemia de por medio, el peronismo
empezó a deshilacharse.
Por momentos todo parecía un auténtico desastre:
N7(20 de febrero de 2021:El escándalo de
las vacunas en Argentina: el ministro de Salud
dimite tras conocerse la vacunación irregular
de funcionarios y otras personalidades.
BBC)
N8(28 de junio de 2021: Argentina sigue siendo
el peor país en pasar la pandemia según
el ranking de Bloomberg.
Iprofesional)
N9(17 de junio de 2021: La educación argentina
en su peor momento.
A fines del año pasado, el investigador de
FLACSO Agustín Claus alertó sobre una proyección
que mostraba que casi 1,5 millones de chicos
abandonaron la escuela después de la cuarentena.
La Nación)
Y luego llegó la inflación del 40, el 50,
el 80 y hasta del 100%.
La falta de reservas y toda la crisis que
está atravesando el país.
Que es de lo que ya os hablamos aquí en VisualPolitik
en el vídeo sobre el fin del peronismo que
publicamos hace algunos días.
Argentina empezaba a querer un cambio y ahora
ya había más opciones.
No había porque limitarse al gradualismo.
Mucha gente estaba harta y querían un líder
firme, claro, decidido.
Ese fue el mejor caldo de cultivo para que
el relato libertario de Milei pudiera cuajar.
(Yo no me metí en esto para estar guiando
corderos, yo me metí acá para despertar
leones.
¡Quiero escucharlos rugir!
¡Viva la Libertad Carajo!)
Y eso es exactamente lo que paso.
Milei empezó a trabajar su candidatura presidencial
en 2022.
Y apenas un año más tarde el resultado estaba
servido.
(“Hoy nos hemos puesto de pie para decirle
basta al modelo de la decadencia.
Hoy dimos el primer paso para la reconstrucción
de la Argentina”.
)
(“Invito a los argentinos a sumarse a la
revolución liberal que va a hacer que en
35 años Argentina vuelva a ser una potencia
mundial.
Muchas gracias y ¡Viva la Libertad Carajo!
¡Viva la Libertad Carajo!)
Ahora, por supuesto, el gran reto son las
elecciones.
Y aquí, a diferencia de Juntos por el Cambio,
el proyecto la Libertad Avanza está mucho
más cohesionado.
Todo gira en torno a Milei.
Un candidato que ahora ya sí puede reclamar
así el voto útil contra el peronismo.
Los números de Milei dicen que está en disposición
de ganar, especialmente si logrará una segunda
vuelta frente al candidato peronista Sergio
Massa.
Lo que no parece un escenario descabellado.
Se da, por hecho, salvo debacle económica
en los próximos meses, que una parte importante
de los votos que en las primarias fueron a
Larreta podrían ir no a Bullrich sino al
candidato peronista.
Si eso es así, Bullrich necesitaría movilizar
una gran parte del voto que no ha participado
en las primarias para sí mismo.
No parece un reto particularmente fácil.
Y eso es lo que explica que Wells Fargo le
dé un 65% de posibilidades de ser presidente.
En cambio, si Bullrich logrará superar a
Massa y pasar a segunda vuelta frente a Milei,
entonces la lucha probablemente estaría mucho
más reñida [En cualquier caso, todo apunta
a que el peronismo lo tiene muy crudo.]
Todo esto, claro está, si Milei no tienes
más traspiés como este respecto a la venta
de órganos.
Cuando vos no permitirse esto, la cantidad
de órganos que va a haber disponible para
salvar gente es menor, si es menor, porque
que ya los que estaban, estaban, o sea lo
que puedes hacer es que ahora algunas personas
quieran ingresar, o sea es una decisión mía,
como no voy a poder decidir sobre mi cuerpo
El peronismo va a intentar relanzar sus opciones
sobre el voto del miedo.
¿No es acaso esto darles gasolina?
Sea como sea, si algo está claro es que hoy
por hoy Milei tiene muchas probabilidades
de terminar siendo el presidente de la Argentina.
Y la pregunta, lógicamente, es, ¿Qué planes
tiene?
¿En qué se basa la revolución que quiere
sacar adelante para volver a convertir a la
Argentina en un país rico y próspero?
Alberto, todo tuyo.
Gracias, Enrique.
Pues en primer lugar promete llevar a cabo
una gran reforma del Estado.
Se ha comprometido a reducir el gasto público
un 15% de forma inminente, pasar de 18 a 8
el número de ministerios, acabar progresivamente
con los pagos sociales, sustituir la obra
pública por concesiones y privatizar muchas
de las empresas que todavía son propiedad
del Estado.
Hablamos por ejemplo de Aerolíneas Argentinas
o la petrolera YPF.
Es lo que los libertarios han denominado como
el “Plan Motosierra”.
Ministerio de turismo y deporte afuera
Ministerio de cultura afuera Ministerio de
ambiente y desarrollo sostenible afuera Ministerio
de las mujeres y género y diversidad afuera
Ministerio de Obras Públicas afuera, aunque
te resistas
Pero eso no es todo.
En paralelo, Milei también se ha comprometido
a impulsar una gran reforma de la educación
y también del sistema sanitario.
La idea del candidato libertario pasaría
por garantizar el acceso universal a estos
servicios, pero cambiando el sistema actual
por uno de seguros en el caso de la sanidad
o cheques, vouchers en el caso de la educación.
De esta forma, los argentinos recibirían
un derecho que luego podrían canjear por
el seguro médico y los centros educativos
que ellos escogieran.
De esta forma, el modelo generaría competencia
y los actores privados podrían competir en
igualdad de condiciones.
Con el tiempo, se entiende, que recibir el
cheque educativo o que el Estado corriera
con el coste del seguro médico se iría limitando
en función de la renta.
Y así, poco a poco se podría crear un sistema
al que todos tendrían acceso, pero que tendría
más competencia, mucho menos coste para las
arcas públicas y una forma de funcionar más
eficiente.
Asimismo, Milei ha defendido un millón de
veces el comercio libre, y eso es exactamente
lo que quiere para el país: que reduzca todas
las barreras posibles y se abra de forma unilateral
al comercio mundial.
Y luego, por supuesto, la que podemos considerar
como su propuesta estrella: según Milei el
plan definitivo para acabar con el eterno
problema de la inflación en Argentina: Estamos
hablando, por supuesto, de la dolarización
del país.
Nosotros proponemos un sistema de competencia
de moneda a la luz de lo que eligió los argentinos
a lo largo de la historia es el dólar por
lo tanto vamos a liquidar el Banco Central
en dólares
Y junto a todo ello, Milei también promete
acabar muchas de las regulaciones que afectan
a la vida económica argentina.
Hablamos de regulaciones laborales, regulaciones
de precios, regulaciones profesionales o,
también, reducciones de impuestos.
Y junto a todo ello, Milei también promete
acabar muchas de las regulaciones que afectan
a la vida económica argentina.
Hablamos de regulaciones laborales, regulaciones
de precios, regulaciones profesionales o,
también, reducciones de impuestos.
a no podría sumar mucho más que unos 40
diputados y 8 senadores.
Esto, por supuesto, le dejaría muy lejos
de poder controlar un Congreso compuesto por
un total de 72 senadores y 257 diputados.
Sí, la suma de la Libertad Avanza y Juntos
por el Cambio tendría una mayoría muy clara…
Pero Milei tendría que negociar.
Y lo tendría que hacer no solo con un único
partido sino con una fuerza legislativa que
en Argentina suele ser bastante heterogénea.
Aunque los candidatos se presenten por una
misma plataforma como Juntos por el Cambio,
suele haber muchas corrientes diferentes.
La pregunta es…
¿Sería Milei capaz de negociar y llegar
acuerdos con la oposición?
Pues…
Lo cierto es que él mismo tiene dudas de
que ese proceso pudiera llegar a buen puerto,
sobre todo con lo que respecta a las grandes
reformas.
Eso sí, dice tener un plan.Es decir, prácticamente
lo que Javier Milei quiere es transformar
de arriba abajo el sistema productivo del
país.
Entonces la pregunta que temores que hacernos,
lógicamente es, ¿realmente todo esto es
posible?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2(¿GOBERNAR CON MOTOSIERRA?)
Queridos amigos, amigas, lógicamente para
llevar a cabo todas las reformas prometidas
por Milei, no solo necesitaría ganar las
presidenciales, también tendría que conseguir
el apoyo del parlamento.
El problema es que en Argentina la renovación
de las cámaras es parcial.
En cada elección se renueva la mitad de la
Cámara de Diputados y un tercio del Senado.
Esto quiere decir, que incluso si el partido
de Milei obtiene en la primera vuelta el mismo
nivel de apoyo que en las PASO, esta agrupación
libertaria.
Yo me comprometo frente a la población a
dolarizar, y si la casta política no lo deja
hacer convocó a un referéndum, vas a ver
lo que dice la gente.
El candidato libertario ha dicho que recurriría
a las consultas populares.
Y no solo en el caso de la dolarización,
sino también para otras muchas políticas,
incluyendo temas de alto voltaje como, por
ejemplo, la legalización del aborto.
Esto es algo que despierta ciertas inquietudes
no solo dentro del entorno político, sino
que también existen serias dudas sobre el
encaje jurídico de esta acción.
Y es que aquí la ley - una ley que no podría
cambiar sin el acuerdo con la oposición - parece
bastante clara:
C1(La ley de convocatoria a consulta popular
vinculante deberá tratarse en una sesión
especial y ser aprobada con el voto de la
mayoría absoluta de miembros presentes en
cada una de las Cámaras.
Artículo 2 de la ley 25.432 sobre Consulta
Popular Vinculante y No Vinculante.)
Es decir, el presidente Milei solo podría
convocar sin aprobación legislativa previa
referéndums no vinculantes.
Sí, podría presentar un ref eréndum, ganarlo
y entonces presionar al Congreso.
Pero tened una cosa clara: esto generaría
mucha, muchísima tensión...
Y no solo eso, tampoco sería un proceso particularmente
rápido.
Amigos, Milei está creando muchas expectativas…
Y un posible bloqueo político podría bien
hacerle perder su proyección política o
para intentar mantener el barco a flote, lanzarse
al cuello del legislativo…
Lo que vete tú a saber cómo terminaría.
Desde luego no sería nada bueno.
Esos son los dos grandes riesgos que existen.
Porque el problema, y lo hemos visto en otros
países de América Latina, se produce cuando
un presidente crea muchas expectativas y luego
no tiene apoyo para llevar a cabo los cambios
prometidos.
Insisto, esto no quiere decir que Milei no
podría llegar a salirse con la suya, por
ejemplo, logrando un gran acuerdo con Juntos
por el Cambio o utilizando inteligentemente
los referéndums no vinculantes para en dos
años incrementar su peso legislativo.
Lo que queremos decir es que el riesgo de
que no lo consiga y que eso tenga consecuencias
está sobre la mesa.
Especialmente cuando hablamos de un candidato
que no es partidario de buscar muchos entendimientos.
(Usted se sentaría con ella (Cristina Fernández)
a hablar de una transición si le toca ganar.
No ¿y con Alberto Fernández?
Tampoco)
Claro que, amigos, amigas, quizás haya algo
o alguien que estamos perdiendo de vista.
Un perfil que últimamente actúa entre bambalinas
y que en un futuro no muy lejano puede tener
un rol clave en toda esta historia.
Estamos, hablando, por supuesto, del mismísimo
Mauricio Macri.
Abril de 2023: “Es obvio que pienso que
vamos a ir a una segunda vuelta con esta nueva
expresión más liberal , más rupturista
y de enojo de esta frustración que arrastra
Argentina hace años [...] (el candidato de
Juntos por el Cambio que esté en esa posición)
tendrá que demostrar que, más allá de las
intenciones rupturistas y de cambio que tiene
Milei, nosotros tenemos las mismas, pero con
experiencia y eso debería inclinar la balanza
a favor nuestro”.
Mauricio Macri
El expresidente argentino no solo tuvo una
premonición hace meses sobre la ola libertaria,
sino que desde hace tiempo ha entablado una
cercanía particular con el propio Javier
Milei, hasta tal punto que el año pasado,
el líder libertario planteaba esta posibilidad:
(Yo creo que Macri podría tener un rol muy
importante trabajando en conjunto con la cancillería
Si ella (Patricia Bullrich) digamos quisiera
venir a nuestro espacio digamos esta sería
bien recibida podría ser hasta jefe de gabinete)
Claro que las elecciones y el combate electoral
suelen crear muchas fracturas.
Sea como sea Macri podría ser la llave para
buscar una agenda de reformas conjunta.
Pero por ahora, si algo está claro es que
Milei propone reformar la Argentina de arriba
abajo y que ahora, por primera vez, sí tiene
muchas probabilidades de terminar siendo el
nuevo presidente de la Argentina.
Los riesgos y las oportunidades están sobre
la mesa.
Y a partir de ahí, ya sabéis, no tenemos
una bola de cristal.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, la pregunta es
para ti:
¿Qué opinión tienes de Javier Milei?
¿Qué te parece su programa político?
¿Crees que realmente terminará siendo el
nuevo presidente de la Argentina?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ahora, si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante,
ya sabéis, no olvides darle a like bien fuerte
y suscribiros a VisualPolitik si es que aún
no lo habéis hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.